Daisuke Tanaka Sawa doesn't mess around  I don't know I don't know yes I remember  a protege of the famed Jiro of Tokyo  this is my fault he is now living out  his own dream in your chef Nakazawa  thank you so much for having us nobody  can get a reservation so I need you to  teach me how to actually make the sushi  almost myself what's the first step  awesome sir cut the fish one bells  winner of the blade step 2  right get your hand low it Oh little  vinegar in water for a magic amount a  little right step 3  wasabi a little bit of wasabi on your  finger and just plonk in the middle okay  step 4 nigiri this to finger and they  sound and tongue okay perfect  step 5 garnished open guff  on the skin here Ramo its whole only  deliver come  Monica he'll know better